das nicht los da ist nicht los es ist
einfach den einnahmen selbst auf den
rücken hält lassen schluss dass sofort
den harmlos den du nicht war festhält
den ich mir selbst
herzlich willkommen liebe leute ich hab
weil ihr euch das mit dem stab mal
wieder den rtl2 hilf mir müll dschungel
durchforstet und bin dabei auf 1 4
gestoßen das ja sagen wir mal ist es mir
aufgefallen
ich habe mal gar nicht lange um den
heißen brei herum warum leute ich nenne
ich einfach nur den titel zu diesem
video dann könnt ihr euch kurz eure
gedanken machen und dazu hatten wir auch
direkt rein denn das video was heute
anschauen werden heißt im ernst mein
freund verlässt mich weil ich im
rollstuhl sitze ist natürlich eine
situation die wir alle kennen danke
nochmal rtl2 dass ihr darüber beitrag
gemacht hat möchte jetzt rein
das wird bei der offshore ehrlichkeit
dass der treppe wir uns erstmal da fängt
schon an jo jo stock ok soll allerdings
nicht aus köln komplett nachvollziehen
aber ich bin ein bisschen geschockt dass
es die rohen wurde dass ihr gerade
drehen wir es dem klub da war ich auch
schon das ein oder andere mal selbst ok
alles klar das muss ich vorneweg sagen
aber ansonsten ja die gehen natürlich
jetzt am hellichten tag in club the
weekend's alle also die situation ist
schon komplett beschied man muss aber
zur verteidigung des türstehers sagen
dass er tatsächlich eine sehr große
steile treppe im club ist das ist
ausnahmsweise mal keinen sinn also an
die dame blieben rollstuhl sitzt und
eine club möchte
du kommst wirklich nicht auf die
tanzfläche so das ist eine riesig große
treppe und da ist kein aufzug also das
wird wirklich schwer mit dem rollstuhl
muss ich sagen eben nicht das ist
einfach so
das ist okay dass diskriminierung das
ist auch dass zocker nicht das gewebe
das ist auch keine diskriminierung heute
falls ihr euch gedacht hat das ist eine
diskriminierung bis es nicht was hat
jetzt gesagt okay eins nach dem andern
erfreut dass mit rat und tat sich noch
nicht so sehr aufgefallen also der sie
tatsächlich ziemlich auf punkt aus der
sollte sich schon tragen kann aber was
war das von der reaktion von ihm habe
ich einen kittel an sich aus wie ein
krankenpfleger korrekt korrekte freund
das sieht aus wie eine person mit der
man definitiven intensivere romantische
beziehungen eingehen sollte aber jemand
der einem so jedem gefallen verweigert
so zart kannst du bitte mal die
glühbirne rentieren du weißt ich kann da
nicht dran ich bin nicht so groß
was sich aus dem handwerk nicht zu viel
verlangt nicht diese besteht also wir
merken leute die haben auf jeden fall
diese ganze situation und nicht so
durchdacht so als pärchen so komplett
sinnlos als würde man nicht vorher mal
drüber reden so nach dem motto ja ok ja
gehen wir heute den klub ja okay kann
man noch einen schritt weiter denken so
zum beispiel wie sollen wir machen wenn
im club eine treppe ist vielleicht
vorher mal googeln ob der klub eine
steile treppe habt oder nicht dazu sind
die beiden hier scheinbar nicht in der
lage ein scheiß rollstuhl geht man
einfach offen sagt jede kleinigkeit ist
ein problem mit dir jeder chance hier
der fonds müsste sowieso schon längst
wieder laufen können sag mal bist du
mich verarschen
bruder ist dann ernst wahrscheinlich hat
sie sich ausgesucht ob sie das ist im
rollstuhl sitze was für ein idiot erhält
ihr das wirklich so vor als hätte sie so
gesagt du ja da hab ich bock drauf mache
ich jetzt drin zu sitzen meine beine
nicht immer nur auf meinen arsch zu
sitzen
ich würde auch sie beim einlaufen 8 und
warum blick vom typ der da so auf [ __ ]
you warum habe ich bei diesem rtl2
scheiß mitgemacht hat etwas warum mache
ich so was immer irgendwie aber habe ich
überhaupt nicht nötig und eine frau im
rollstuhl habe ich schon mal gar nicht
nötig also sucht den ein freund dafür
[Musik]
bruder war allerdings schluss gemacht
mit ihr ist voll der aktuellen arbeiten
das ist eigentlich das fehler mehr zu
machen so wo ist die vorgeschichte dazu
sie hatte vor drei monaten ihren
autounfall seit drei monaten im
rollstuhl es wird so langsam besser ist
kurz davor wieder gehen zu können erst
seit drei monaten in einer person
zusammen die im rollstuhl sitzt okay
dann auf einmal stehen sie vom klub was
im rollstuhl
wir können dich zusammen im clubraum
okay das war's mal schluss eine freundin
sagte mädel durch die gegend fahren muss
und dann noch das ständige rom gejammert
von ihr was geht gar nicht also ich bin
dafür keine belege
wir alle kennen die situation wo dann
einem auf einmal nach wochen oder
monaten auffällt dass die eigene
freundin die wirklich sehr hübsch ist
außerdem auch noch im rollstuhl sitzen
man natürlich sofort schluss macht ist
ja klar das macht sich auf keinen fall
zum schlechten menschen oder mach dir
keine sorgen
das wird mir auf jeden fall wissen
lassen dass wir heute das ist zwar
bewundert haben auch keine vorgestellt
wie es wäre wenn ich einen unfall hatte
und ich im rollstuhl sitzen will und
dann so meine freunde mit mir schluss
mal weil sie einmal nicht in den club
wir gehen kann weil der krippen steile
treppe hat ich glaube ich könnte nicht
mal traurig sein dem moment schon einmal
so und wird dann einfach kampflos ab
machen oder irgendwas
[Musik]
also wir sehen heute an der stelle hat
rtl2 sich ganz kurz selbst geplant ist
natürlich auch eine allgemein bekannte
erkenntnis dass wunden am eigenen körper
am besten heilen wenn man die eigenen
grenzen komplett ersetzt in dem man rtl2
schaut
[Musik]
aber sorry dies wirklich krank sorry da
aber sicher dass schluss machen willst
du ja das war ein ganz aggressiv was die
rowa ist das goldene schuhe hose auf
drei viertel hochgekrempelt und dann
long die lederjacke das ist auf jeden
fall nicht von der hand zu weisen also
ich musste an der stelle noch mal sagen
der typ der dieser wollte die wirte
vollgepumpte typ da am anfang der wird
sich noch gedanken machen
mit der schluss zu machen das kann heute
keine gute entscheidung
ja ich kann es verstehen aber ich wollte
eigentlich nur kurz was erzählen das
kommt bei uns von einer weiter aus und
du weißt gar nicht was da abgeht
abtransport uhr ist er arbeitet im klub
und sie weiß nicht was da abgeht weil
sie nicht reingelassen würde
ok also muss sagen es läuft relativ
bescheiden für selina soll es dieses
jungfrau sie aber die finnen als
personal trainerin und hat ihren job und
augenscheinlich verloren wegen ihrem
unfall und ihr ex-freund bagger hat
jetzt die frau an die jetzt ihren job
macht muss nicht besonders kreativ von
rtl2 welche story sich da ausgedacht
haben es einmal so einfach leben
ruinieren
sie lacht sich ja doch echt richtig
dummen abzuraten gewichtig lebt von der
stütze an der stelle haben sondern ich
zähle auch beendet weil sie aber los
gelacht hat wahrscheinlich nur um es
klarzustellen also dass es in echt
natürlich wenn es dann wirklich passiert
ein hartes schicksal und darüber nicht
lustig machen
ja das ist hilft mir fällt jetzt
getriggert sind nein da kannst du nur
scheiße reden so weit also hat bis dato
tatsächlich nichts sinnvolles sein also
ich glaub schon nicht selina wie scheiße
ist er geht und ich probiere sie zu
motivieren browser auf macht alles
mögliche was machst du jetzt hier ein
aufrechter der rollstuhlfahrer oder was
egal was du diese typen los machst du
jetzt ein aufrechter der rollstuhlfahrer
aber wer hat dir ins hirn geschissen
ich bin wenigstens freuen und will ihr
helfen ging war das scheint du hast ja
einfach nur sitzen lassen besser wäre
ich doch doch also ich meine immer
schwierig so zu sagen was ein mensch
besser ist als andere aber
disqualifiziert sich selbst wissen mit
diesen sprüchen leute krank das
gewaltverbrechen schaut mal hin ist
wirklich das wirklich hart kommen was
hier abgeht ok den einnahmen selbst auf
den rücken hält lassen schloss das
sofort den harmlos die du nicht mal fest
[Musik]
was jetzt los waren jetzt doch im klub
und warum warum schon wieder am
helllichten tag
kein mensch geht am hellichten tag in
clubs kann mir keiner erzählen das ist
auch schon wieder so typisch sorry also
mehr lautet geht's nicht haben
wahrscheinlich die drehgenehmigung für
so einen ort nur für die rothenburg
diesen klub da wo die eine gerade raus
kommt deswegen stehen wieder alle leute
auf einem fleck so es ist nicht so als
wäre köln die stadt in der das nie
gedreht wird die stadt mit einer million
einwohnern die riesig ausgedehnt nein
alles was in köln passiert passiert im
umkreis von drei metern um diesen klub
[Musik]
leute also es ist wirklich sehr viele
leute man wir kennen alle die
situationen wo man am hellichten tage um
so circa 15 uhr aus dem klub rauskommt
man ist immer noch perfekt gestylten
sieht nicht aus wie eine leiche und hat
in der handtasche die man in seinem
rollstuhl versteckt hat noch eine
flasche champagner mitgehen lassen
das ganze vernachlässig vollkommen den
fakt dass der club wirklich eine
geisteskrank steile treppe hat die kein
rollstuhl hoch oder runter kommt man auf
aber okay das war zu weit gewesen dass
mit dem ersten teil direkt zu noch
dieses video der zweite teil von morgen
ihr kriegt hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das video hier könnte man
kann aber den film versucht den schritt
morgen einen vorteil 2 bis dann ist auch
augen macht's gut